It may sound strange,
but as a liberal,
I really do believe in American
exceptionalism due to our democratic
ideals and personal freedoms in America
is a unique and special country in the
world.
I really do believe that.
You may remember back in 2009 when
President Obama said he didn't really
believe in American exceptionalism
saying quote,
I believe in American exceptionalism
just as I suspect that the Brits believe
in British exceptionalism and the Greeks
believe in Greek exceptionalism in and
of itself.
There's nothing wrong with Obama's
general idea here in which each
individual country is filled with proud
people who believe that their country is
unique and special in the world.
Actually,
this idea of fuels people to build a
better society that they can be
genuinely proud of.
Then fantastic.
Of course,
by the same token,
this nationalism could also push
otherwise good people to believe that
they should have inordinate sway over
the world or influence other nations
because they're morally superior.
Over the eight years of Obama's
presidency,
he walked back this statement and did
actually say that America's
exceptionalism was unique for me.
There's an additional reason for
American exceptionalism,
which goes beyond just our democratic
ideals and our personal freedoms.
Obviously we are the only country in the
world to share those ideas.
It's also the additional piece that
America is a country of immigrants,
a country of people from all over the
world who came here to make a better
life for themselves.
We are a nation built by people whose
ancestors often came here with nothing
and who worked hard to build a better
country and life for their children and
their children's children.
While we certainly aren't the only
country to welcome immigrants or to
build a solid middle class,
there's no other nation on earth that
more people from more countries have
come to live and prosper because of the
pursuit of happiness.
This doesn't mean that everyone can come
here and we can have open borders,
but it does mean that if you come here
illegally,
you'll be given the same chance as a
natural born citizen.
Even today,
as we live in a politically fractured
society,
and many people will tell you that
things have never been worse.
The truth is that things have actually
never been better.
Now,
of course,
I don't mean that for every specific
person or every specific job or specific
industry times change and soda people
and economies,
but as a whole,
America has done an incredible job of
welcoming so many diverse people having
us all share in the American dream,
while at the same time all being able to
keep traditions and practices from our
unique cultures.
As our economy changes over the next few
years,
we the people have a massive job of
changing along with it.
In an age where supermarkets will be
automated and driverless cars will
replace truck drivers,
it will be more important than ever for
us to change along with the technology.
The world doesn't stop for anyone or
anything.
You have to adapt to a changing world
and in these moments of change,
that's usually where America has been at
its best.
Our system built on the idea that it's
your job to pursue your happiness is the
reason that more people still want to
come to America right now than any other
country on earth.
I always find it ironic that so many
people who rant and rave about how evil
America is are the same people who
demand that we let anyone in here.
Why would anyone want to come to such an
evil,
unfair and oppressive society?
Of course,
this is nonsense and these people know
it.
There's a reason that people don't leave
America in droves.
Even the celebrities who said they would
leave if trump was elected have somehow
managed to stay here for the record.
I'm pretty sure that Canada is happy
that they didn't have to take in most of
those people.
I mentioned all of this because for all
the goodness here in America,
we obviously still have some work to do.
Every society has worked to do,
which is why people peddling utopia are
always frauds.
In Liars.
In America,
though almost every generation has
fought to expand rights to other people,
not to limit them.
That's how we got women the right to
vote.
That's how we freed the slaves and
that's how gay people were allowed to
marry and that's how whatever will come
next will arrive.
As for that work that we have to do,
I think a lot of it has to do with how
we can come together instead of just
ripping each other apart.
I'm a firm believer that most of us want
the same things in life.
We want to work a decent job,
eat some good food,
have some sex,
and go on vacation now and again,
most of us aren't racist,
homophobe secretly plotting against each
other and trying to push our way of life
on everyone else.
This is somewhere which no matter where
your political leanings are,
we can all come together.
Yes,
some of us are from big cities,
some of us are from small towns.
Some of us have had ancestors who
arrived on the mayflower and some of us
just arrived yesterday,
but the only way this all works is if we
all bend to fit the American ideals of
freedom and of liberty,
not if we demand that the system bend to
us.
My guest this week is comedian trae
crowder.
Trey is known as the liberal redneck.
Apparently they do exist.
His comedy is a blend of showing liberal
elites that rednecks aren't all
backwards Hicks and showing rednecks
that liberals aren't all evil
socialists.
It's almost as if we should judge people
as individuals,
not as groups.
Where have I heard that before?
You know the middle of this country for
a long time has been the brunt of jokes
and the easy way to make fun of anyone
who thinks differently than the people
in New York or Los Angeles.
As someone who has only lived in New
York or Los Angeles,
I've never subscribed to this way of
thinking and I've tried not to mock
people just because they talk
differently or haven't evolved on some
social views.
The second that I have,
whether you're a Democrat or Republican,
straight or gay,
black or white,
native American or new immigrants,
this country belongs to all of us and it
needs all of us to continue to make it
better.
That's the thing with exceptionalism.
It takes an awful lot of work to keep
up.
Joining me this week is a comedian and
author,
a redneck and liberal cray crowder.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
I've gotten to here in mind a redneck
and a liberal that throws people a lot.
Do I have to even ask you a question to
start this thing or do I just hand it to
you there?
Well,
the,
so what has become my favorite way to
define that?
I was actually was actually said to me
at one of my comedy shows in Austin,
Texas.
I guy from Mississippi who now lives in
Austin.
I fan came up to me and was talking to
me and he was like,
he seemed so genuinely frustrated too
about like all the,
how he's been stereotyped or whatever
for being a redneck or whatever else.
He's like,
man,
I,
you know,
I like to blow shit up,
but I ain't fucking racist.
Eddie seemed like so upset about it.
I was wanting to put my hand on his
shoulder.
I was like,
I know buddy.
It's all right.
You know what I mean?
But,
but yeah,
basically just,
you know,
I grew up in,
I was very stereotypically redneck
fashion,
uh,
you know,
dirt poor and the middle of nowhere,
Tennessee.
And I mean,
it would be redneck by basically any
standard,
but I've never,
I've never subscribed to any of those
sort of like a,
you know,
to me regressive ideologies and stuff
that rednecks or stereotypical known for
and I didn't even,
it never even really all that weird to
me.
Well,
I've known for awhile now that it's
weird,
but I'm saying I never even had to
really think about it.
That's just how I will make a conscious
decision to be this,
you know,
Weirdo thing.
That's just how it worked out.
It just happens,
which is pretty much how I think,
how it works for everybody.
Um,
what really,
if you had to define what a redneck is,
what really is a redneck?
Well,
uh,
a lot of people for some reason assume
that black,
I'm like opposed to this guy for
whatever reason.
But I actually have a lot of respect for
him.
But I think Jeff foxworthy defined it
the best.
It involves the TV on another team.
So not yet.
Obviously you made a whole career out of
defining,
but he got assets.
I watched a lot of the way he ultimately
defined it was he said it's the glorious
absence of sophistication,
which I pretty well agree with and in
our book that we wrote with my tour
mates,
cory and drew,
we sort of added an addendum to that,
which was a not given a damn.
Generally speaking about how people feel
about you and the way you live your life
and whatever.
You know what I mean?
I'd do what I do and I liked what I like
and I don't give a damn what you think
about it or not.
That coupled with the aforementioned
lack of sophistication a is what makes a
redneck to me.
Yeah.
So interestingly,
it's not really.
Even though I think people will
prescribe political leanings to redness
in and of itself,
it's not really,
it's just the idea
of Sorta I do what I do.
Yeah.
And want to be left alone and you know,
want to have a good time and all that
kind of stuff.
And I honestly,
and I feel so I guess naive or ignorant
or whatever saying this now,
but I genuinely didn't realize that to
so many people it had those like
political connotations or whatever.
Don't get me wrong,
I knew rednecks were stereotyped as
being,
you know,
dumb or,
and Brad or racist or whatever.
I knew those things existed,
but I didn't know that to so many
people.
Like,
part of the definition of the word
redneck is a regressive,
racist,
homophobe who hates books and loves
Jesus now.
You know what I mean?
Like,
that's right.
That's what it means to people.
And like nothing else,
I didn't realize that that existed at
the level that it does until very
recently.
Yeah.
And you've done a bunch of videos on
youtube.
I think untangling some of that stuff
and showing people.
Actually no,
that's not really all there is to this
stuff.
But how poor did you grow up because
you're white,
so I assume you get white privileged.
Did you not have a lot of white
privilege growing up?
Big Whitey.
So I've actually had to get used to
being white.
Uh,
as I've gotten into the middle class and
stuff in the past few years,
like that's a recent phenomenon for me.
I tell people that sometimes it's true
and I know it sounds weird to people.
I never felt white growing up.
I don't mean to imply that I felt black
or it's like,
oh,
you know what I mean,
that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is my whole life when
I've heard about white people and white
people do,
I've caught a flight,
you know,
a Connecticut,
like very Yuppie Ish.
Like,
you know,
uh,
the landed gentry,
you know what I mean?
Like that's what I thought of when I
heard of white people and I never,
we were white trash,
which is completely different,
you know what I mean?
Like I point out all the time,
I a good example,
I like to use this cops right?
And now don't get me wrong,
they're not shooting rednecks in the
streets,
but it's a well established thing
culturally that like cops and rednecks
don't get along.
You know what I mean?
Every episode of cops they ever made in
the ghetto or the trailer park,
you know what I mean?
So like there was definitely that
feeling of like,
I don't know.
No,
I never felt privileged at all.
To answer your question.
I mean that's not the same as saying
that I don't think white privilege like
exist in a lot of arenas or whatever it
does,
but I think if you're poor,
it doesn't really matter very much.
The good thing is though,
there's a good thing,
but if you manage to become not poor and
you're a white man than hey,
let's just isis.
Yeah.
So now I don't know.
I don't know how much you have,
but you're doing all right now you're on
tour,
you're doing good stuff.
You got some,
some TV things cooking.
Now you've,
you've gotten yourself out of white
trash that I managed to escape,
which is not easy.
Now you can summer in the Hamptons and
go to Connecticut on that level.
Well it's just at the beginning.
You know,
it's funny about that is mop my whole
life.
I've had this thing where you mentioned
like the Hamptons.
I've never been,
but like I promise you if I,
if me and you went to the hamptons right
now and we like pull it and we first get
in there and whatever,
I would immediately become very
uncomfortable and it's,
and it's an uncommon,
it's a discomfort is in a,
like a,
I don't belong here kind of way,
but then there's also an element of
like,
they know they're going to be able to
tell,
like look at me and like who's who let
the,
you know,
trailer trash in here,
whatever.
And I know that that's irrational,
but I really do like feel that I have.
Yeah.
So okay.
So you grow up white trash,
redneck community in Tennessee.
Give me some of the good stuff about
that because you've talked about the
good stuff in the values and that kind
of stuff.
Well,
nature is a big one.
Like it's absolutely beautiful.
They are.
The best part about my home county is
the,
like Dale Hollow,
like objectively awesome.
Like,
and so if you're in Danny outdoorsy
stuff,
we've got that in spades.
Uh,
and yeah,
the sense of community.
Everybody knows everybody.
There's cons to that too,
obviously.
Obviously there's a lot of good things
about it,
like people actually genuinely care
about each other for the most part.
And also,
um,
the food.
I'm a huge fan of,
you know what I mean?
My,
my,
uh,
my grandmas,
both of them,
you know,
what most people would call soul food or
whatever I guess,
but just,
you know,
frying everything,
whatever else.
Not good for the arteries,
but good for the soul.
There you go.
Uh,
the music,
I think the south as far as regions go,
I think the south has the best music or
produces the best music in the country,
maybe the world.
And um,
just the way I mentioned earlier a lot,
you know,
people like to have a good time,
you know what I mean?
Like people are not a very tightly wound
there.
You know what I mean?
It's a lot more like laid back and uh,
just like relaxed atmosphere and none of
that whole black stereotypical rat race
stuff that happens.
You don't have any of that.
It's weird because sometimes I like
neat.
There's a part of me that needs that or
wants that obviously,
or I wouldn't be doing any of this,
but there's also a part of me that
appreciates that more like pastoral type
thing in my hometown.
Sure.
What,
what about,
what about some of the political stuff
when you add that to this?
So,
so far we got,
we got kind of the good stuff,
uh,
but you know,
the political stuff is where people
start going out there and they're all
backwards.
What's weird to me,
and I've talked to like people from
places like I'm from about this a lot
and they pretty well agree with it.
Like as a kid growing up,
people were mostly a political.
I'm not saying they were like Democrats
or anything like that.
It's just like I don't,
they didn't really care.
It was like,
it seemed to be more of an attitude of
like,
ah,
the hell with them all,
you know what I mean?
They're all full of shit.
I don't care about us,
you know?
And I mean,
and that was pretty much it and
obviously that has changed,
but I've been gone from the town I grew
up in for 12 years now and obviously a
lot has changed since I left because
it's not like that didn't exist,
but I was never aware of it being this
big,
like curl cultural dividing factor or
whatever.
Most people just didn't,
just didn't really talk about it or
whatever as I was growing up,
uh,
but,
but then,
um,
my hometown is a good example,
the factory lift and went to Mexico
after Nafta and all that,
you know,
and that the ripple effects of that were
sort of,
it took awhile for it to get as bad as
it is now.
And I mean it's bad and has been bad for
years,
like over 13,
14 percent unemployment or whatever for
over a decade now.
And that's just made a lot of people,
you know,
angry,
frustrated and upset and whatever else.
And that wasn't really the case when I
was a kid or not on the level that it is
now.
And I think that's really what it's
about.
They've gotten pissed,
you know,
because they're like way of life has
been altered very negatively.
There's a lot of them and so I think
that's where they've gotten so riled up
and mad like they are now because I'm
not trying to like they were this
enlightened group because they weren't.
But when I was living there and growing
up there just it,
they didn't have this like rage age they
have now.
You know what I mean?
It just wasn't as much of a thing.
It's so.
It's kind of weird to me too,
honestly.
Doesn't that say something interesting
just about economics in general like
that you grew up around this,
but there was a factory so people were
working,
so even if things weren't perfect,
it's,
it's life,
it's life.
Like everybody else has been.
The jobs go away and then suddenly it
actually changes everything.
Yeah.
Because I mean at any time,
obviously you're not unique to salon in
my hometown,
this is the story I'm most places like
that,
but so the jobs leave and then.
And then,
you know,
the pills come in or the math or
whatever,
drug use substance abuse goes through
the roof,
sodas,
you know,
crime like theft,
whatever,
things like that.
The businesses start shuttering the
downtown areas like,
you know,
totally dilapidated and whatever else.
And it just brings everybody way down
and it's just this like cycle of
horrible.
She hit that,
you know.
And uh,
yeah.
And it really,
you know,
really pisses people off or get them
going or both or whatever.
Yeah.
All right.
So before we go any further,
I feel like I have to get your liberal
credit too because I know we're going to
talk a little bit about what we both
feel like it's happening on the left.
And I always say like,
guys,
I'm still a liberal.
I'm gay marriage,
I'm for legalizing marijuana.
I'm pro choice.
I believe in state education.
Uh,
and,
and the list goes on and on.
I'm against the death penalty and for
reforming prison system,
all,
all of that stuff.
These are liberal things.
So can you just lay out some liberal
credits so that 10 minutes from now when
we get onto some other stuff,
people go,
wait a minute,
he really liberal Gimme Gimme some
liberal stuff.
Uh,
I agree with literally everything you
just named off.
I agree with all of those sort of a
gateway.
Liberalism for me was,
uh,
equal rights for gay people because my
uncle is gay and I've found that out
when I was like eight or nine and a,
which is when I found that what gave and
it was,
you know what I mean?
I didn't even know anything about it
before that.
And as soon as I learned what gay men I
learned how your uncle,
he's gay.
Oh,
okay.
Whatever.
But that I started picking up on things
before just went over my head that like,
you know,
these rednecks or whatever that I was
grown up around that they were saying or
that the church was saying about gay
people.
And I immediately didn't like it,
you know what I mean?
And um,
that sort of pushed me in that direction
I think.
And so that's always been a big thing
for me because I take it a little
personally because of my uncle whom I
love dearly,
but then everything else you named from
the prison reform very,
very against the war on drugs,
vr.
That's another thing that I feel very
strongly about because it's also
personal because my mom is a recovering
drug addict who also was a drug dealer
who went to prison.
So like,
I'm all that very personal to me too.
And I completely agree with it.
Uh,
it's like I'm a believer,
obviously it needs to be done the right
way,
but I'm a believer in universal
healthcare.
I also am very pro food stamps and
welfare and things like that.
I've always felt like it would be baldly
hypocritical of me if I wasn't because
like I survived on food stamps as a kid
and you know what I mean,
like one food stamps,
I don't know what would've happened to
me.
So,
you know,
I,
I feel like I'm living proof that those
systems can work,
you know what I mean?
And yeah,
they get abused.
But that's just the reality.
I've asked my attitude towards that has
always been,
but what is the alternative though?
Letting kids go hungry because I'm not
willing to do that,
so we got to just put up with some of
the abuses.
That's how I've looked at it.
So,
um,
yeah,
all the info.
I think eventually we're going to need a
universal basic income because I don't
think there's going to be enough jobs
that exist for the amount of people that
we have.
So I think it's just,
just the reality of where the world is
going on and all that stuff is pretty
liberal.
You're a liberal.
I believe it.
Now,
I believe.
Did you see this story this week about
Amazon is going to have a supermarket
with three employees because everything
else,
you're just going to walk in,
scan your phone,
you take it,
you leave.
They uh,
I saw,
uh,
they,
I think they put it together.
It's like a promo video or something for
that on Youtube that I saw a couple of
weeks ago.
Yeah.
You just
literally walk in,
just get whatever you want,
throw it in a bag and walk out because
they've got scanners
or whatever.
Yeah,
I mean in that kind of thing is not
going away.
One of the biggest ones,
I think everybody realizes at this point
how close we're getting to self driving
vehicles.
I mean that's happening.
There's no doubt that that's happening.
And a truck drivers,
that's like the number one occupation in
something like 37 of the 50 states in
this country or something like that.
The most popular job as a truck driver,
the minute that they have freight that
can be fully automated reliably and
safely,
they will and all of that will just go
away overnight and that's going to
happen in a lot of industries too and
I'm saying,
what else are we going to do?
You know what I mean?
So that's just how.
I just think again,
that's the reality of it is take
something like a universal basic income
or you think that that would be the
answer more than basically retraining an
entire population to either fix
computers or the robots or the drones
or,
or any of that.
So that may be a bridge too far,
but I,
I,
yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
So you're not going to take a truck
driver and have them fixed and groans
just as.
No,
I'm not.
And also I think even if you tried to do
that,
no matter how many drop drones there
are,
I mean if you think about,
let's say like every one robot replaces
one person in a job capacity,
which is not,
that's not true anymore way,
way more,
but let's.
Even if it is that I would think that a
maintenance person for that robot would
also take care of 30 other robots.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not going to be broken down
all the time.
You understand what I'm saying?
So you can take the one guy that
replaces and he's going to fix robots
now.
Well,
he's not going to just fix the one robot
that took his job,
he's going to fix 40 robots.
So and,
and again,
the reality is one robot replaces 15
people or whatever.
When you just follow that,
you know,
that logic down,
it just doesn't track for me.
Even if you wanted to do that retraining
of people or whatever else,
the numbers just don't add up to me.
But I mean I'm not,
I'm not an economist.
I'm a comedian.
I don't know what the hell I'm talking
about.
It's pretty good in the scheme of
economic sense.
I understand that.
It's weird to be alive at the time when
we know robots are going to replace us,
you know,
like where it's not science fiction
anymore.
Now it's like,
Oh yeah,
20 years from now we're all,
when they started to talk show hosts
Comedians,
we're all going to be replaced by
robots.
Yeah.
And in 20 years er might be list,
you know,
people in San Francisco will be getting
super pissed at Alabama for having like
anti robot laws like that.
You know what I mean?
Alabama was going to be discriminating
against a robot.
Americans or whatever will becoming an
episode of Futurama.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's wild.
So I want to back up for a second.
So your uncle that you mentioned,
and I've heard you talk about how he
influenced your sort of awakening to
this stuff,
so people might find that interesting
that there,
there was a gay man,
you know,
let's say 15 years ago or so in the
south that existed.
How is life for him?
I,
I know that sounds sort of ridiculous,
but I think people actually don't
understand that you're right.
But even before gay marriage,
gay people existed.
Lived lives,
some good,
some bad,
you know,
just like everybody else.
Well,
so when I was a kid,
my uncle lived in Nashville and the
thing,
another thing a lot of people don't
realize is that for the most part,
in a lot of ways,
cities are cities,
whether it,
you know,
Birmingham,
Alabama,
it's still a city,
which means there's still plenty of like
liberal ideals and whatever else there.
And so like he lived in Nashville,
which is totally different,
totally different than Salana,
but he came back a lot and then when I
was in high school from then on,
he did live in salina and now I've
thought before and after,
now that I'm an adult,
that may be,
there's a good possibility that he did
go through a lot of shitty things,
shitty treatment,
whatever else.
But like he didn't tell me about it
because I was a kid and he doesn't,
you know what I mean.
And I had enough bad shit going on.
He didn't want to burden me with it or
whatever.
And that's a very good possibility.
But so far as I'm aware,
he never faced any.
Like he definitely never gotten beat up.
He never got like,
you know,
he had a deli,
they're in town for awhile or whatever
else and he never got like a brick
thrown through the window or nothing
like that.
And then,
um,
he's not the only gay guy in the town
either.
In fact,
there was a guy,
and I don't know if there's a local
businessman who is a gay guy.
And when,
um,
when I was in high school,
he used to,
he had a lot of money,
especially for that area.
And so when we were in high school,
he'd come to high school ball games and
Celina Tennessee with like two little,
like a Cuban boy toys.
Seriously,
there are a lot of Catholic boy,
Tennessee.
I don't know where he got them.
That's what I'm saying.
Nobody did.
But what I mean is like,
I mean,
he flaunted it.
Yeah.
And nothing ever happened to him either.
Everybody was just Kinda like,
oh,
that's Steve,
you know,
how Steve Is,
you know what I mean?
And that was like what happened with the
Cubans that,
well,
you know,
he was done with them.
I went back or whatever he got and then
it got to a Ukrainian boy toys or
whatever.
I don't know.
But.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Um,
and that's,
I didn't,
again at the time,
I didn't realize how insane that would
probably be to a lot of people to know
that that had happened there and they
didn't get tarred and feathered or
whatever,
that it was just a thing that people.
I mean,
you know,
that people were definitely like,
Oh God,
here he goes again.
You know what I mean?
But he's in.
That was like the extent of it and
that's still not okay to be disgusted by
gay people obviously,
but like,
it never translated to any kind of like
violence or like,
you know,
get the hell out of our town types.
I never saw anything like that,
but mostly just don't talk about it,
you know what I mean?
You know,
weird way though.
That actually
is okay.
Right.
Because it's like you actually are
allowed to be disgusted by somebody or
be racist or b.
You know what I mean?
Like you can be like,
yeah,
we don't like it.
You know,
you shouldn't dislike someone because of
the color of their skin or their
secretary.
But at the end of the day you're saying
it's a lot of live and let live people
there.
So even if they saw it,
they didn't like it.
As long as you're not hurting somebody,
then what are you gonna do?
I can remember once when I was a kid at
some,
like,
like practice or something.
Some older kid was giving me shit
because my uncle was gay or whatever,
which wasn't a rare thing and after it's
over some,
this guy who I still like,
he's one of the most outwardly
stereotypical redneck people.
You couldn't imagine that.
I mean he is,
he's openly redneck type guy,
right?
Like I mean as red as it gets,
especially in this place.
And like he came up to me afterwards,
you know,
and it was like,
he was like,
I,
your uncle's good,
my in tray,
you know,
don't let them get whatever.
Like that kind of thing.
And that's what I'm saying.
There was a lot of that too.
Like,
I don't know,
it's way,
way more complicated than people
realize,
like it's not just this but,
but then I meet people,
I meet people on the road,
I've got a lot of gay fans and so like
I,
I meet gay people in like Portland or
wherever who grew up in Alabama,
you know what I mean?
And there they just have just horror
stories,
you know what I mean?
So like,
and I know they're not lying.
I know that's the reality.
So again,
it's complicated,
you know,
so you're telling me your personal
experience can blanket the entire thing.
I can't believe it.
That's crazy.
My anecdotal experience,
it's not as bad as people think it is,
but there's still a lot of room for
improvement.
Where does the religion piece get mixed
in that?
Because I think a lot of the sort of the
coast,
you know,
the New York la sort of hatred or
mocking of rednecks and southern culture
is because of the religious attachment,
particularly Christianity because it's
the easiest thing to attack all the
time.
How much of that stuff is associated
with religion do you think?
Couple years ago I would've told you
just about every single bit of it.
I used to,
when people ask me how I became a
liberal redneck or whatever,
I would talk about my uncle like I
already did,
but the effect that that had was I
stopped going to church because of all
the homophobic shit they were spouting
or whatever.
And I was like,
well to hell with that,
you know,
like why would I take Jesus aside over
my uncle?
You know what I mean?
I never even emailed Jesus,
you know what I mean,
like I'm not going to take his.
So I left the church and that and so
that's what I always thought.
That's what I always attributed a lot of
that too and I blame the church for a
lot of these attitudes in the past.
I've really been enlightened a lot
myself in the past couple of years with
the er,
especially the past year being on tour
and talking to so many people in so many
places and my two tour mates and
coauthors,
cory and drew,
they grew up heavily in the church and
ultimately left it with checks out.
After talking to them and talking to so
many other people at shows and stuff.
I don't think it's.
It's that simple.
I think that that has a lot to do with
it a whole lot to do with it,
but I used to buy.
I used to be like,
if there was no.
If we weren't the Bible belt,
if you took all the Jesus out of the
south,
it'd be totally fine.
That's not true.
It's just not because of the economic
factors and you still have the whole
historical factors and racial factors
and all that kind of stuff that wouldn't
go away just because you got rid of
Jesus.
But uh,
so I mean it's,
it definitely has a lot to do with it
though,
for sure,
particularly when it comes to gay
rights,
gay people and Muslims and the way they
feel about those two groups I still
think is mostly Jesus' fault.
So that's,
that's Jesus right there.
Even though Jesus probably would have
been around a lot of Muslims.
It was the Middle East and uh,
yeah.
Well,
I'm not talking about the actual Jesus.
I'm talking about,
you know,
Jesus the first American.
Right,
right,
right.
Who wrote to Texas on a train with the
machine gunners saying that Jesus,
speaking of Jesus.
So tell me about your come to Jesus
moment when you said,
okay,
I am a liberal.
Like when,
so you had your uncle,
you had this sort of awakening,
but when were you like,
this is the political stuff that I
believe in.
Did you have to actually sort of come
out to people that you knew?
Well,
again,
as I mentioned briefly earlier that like
I never,
I never realized it was weird until
probably,
I mean probably either late high school
or college was when I realized how
different it was.
Like I never thought much about the fact
that I disagreed with certain people
about certain things,
but the biggest factor was again,
like I said,
people just didn't really talk about
that stuff.
So it never really got,
you know,
tossed around for me to realize,
Oh man,
we're on completely different pages.
The first time that I can remember
really thinking that outside of just
the,
you know,
gay rights thing,
which I just chalked up as a religious
thing.
Not a political thing was in high
school.
In our English class we would have
debates because we didn't have a debate
team or debate class or nothing.
We'd have debates like once every other
week and one time in debate class thing
was teacher was like,
okay,
so it's like 2000,
two or three.
Everybody.
Everybody thinks we should not go to
war.
Everybody thinks we should go to war
with Iraq,
raise your hand and it's about half the
students or whatever.
And she was like,
okay,
everybody thinks that we shouldn't go
over that.
Right.
Raise your hand.
And it was literally just me.
Like I was the only thing again,
I threw my hand up without even
thinking.
I was like,
yeah,
of course.
But I looked around and I was the only
one and then that other half of the
crowd where,
you know,
she said,
okay,
now if you just don't know or don't
care,
raise your hand.
And that was the other half of the
class.
She was like,
okay,
everybody doesn't care.
You're with trey,
everybody else here on this side or
whatever.
But
that's a pretty enlightened teacher
given you the,
all the people that didn't really care,
giving it to the piece,
get these guy instead of the.
Well it ended up just being me against
all of them,
which I was
fine with.
But um,
but that was probably the first time
that I sort of had that,
as you said,
come to Jesus moment where I realized
that like I wasn't like most of the
people that I was surrounded by.
Yeah.
When did you get into standup?
So wanted to be a standup since I was
12.
I'm Chris Rock's bigger and blacker came
out and watched it with my dad and
that's what I was like,
I want to do that.
But it was never a question of me like
going to college or not.
Like with my dad,
my grandpa,
everybody else.
It's like,
you know,
I was going to go to college,
I going to be the first one from my
family to graduate from college,
whatever else.
Like it was a big thing and so I did and
I'm glad I did.
I don't regret it at all.
But I focused on that for awhile.
And then by the time I got,
I went to business school and by the
time I got out I was 24 and that's when
I was like,
okay,
if I'm ever going to do comedy at all,
it needs to be nail.
Uh,
and so that's when I started,
when I was 24,
six and a half years ago.
God,
you're a success because if you were the
first family member to go to college and
business school and then you became a
failed comedian man,
that,
that would be the worst day possible.
Oh,
it's funny.
My Dad,
my dad was always cool with it.
because my dad was mostly cool with
everything,
you know what I mean?
But my dad would,
when I'd tell him I wanted to be a
comedian or be in Showbiz,
whatever,
he'd be like,
you know what I mean?
But outside of him though,
every other authority figure in my life
from my grandfather's two guidance
counselors,
teachers,
whatever,
because I always made really good grades
and they would tell me like,
you know,
you can,
you have an opportunity to get out of
here and you can do whatever you want.
You can be a lawyer,
you can be a doctor,
you know,
all this stuff.
And I would,
if I told them I think I want to be a
comedian,
they'd be like,
no,
not that,
don't do that,
you know,
like,
you're gonna have.
Yeah,
or whatever.
Like,
you got to do this.
That was the universal response to that
was like,
wow,
he's gonna.
He's gonna waste it all trying to be a
comedian or is what I got a lot of.
But yeah,
it's working out.
Yeah,
it is working.
So now you're in La
[inaudible].
How's La Treatment?
Has their lab
for a redneck?
Well,
it's fun for me.
Uh,
I don't mind it,
you know,
I'm,
I'm doing fine with it.
But,
uh,
I do.
I think it's weird for people around me
a lot.
I definitely get a lot of like a
sideways glances and stuff like that at
times,
like if I got,
I've got two little boys so I've got all
my boys at the park or something and I'm
yelling at them because they're doing
something they shouldn't be doing,
you know what I mean?
But I'm yelling at a child and this like
I ain't got damaged.
I mean with like a trucker hat on and
whatever else.
And then I noticed that like,
oh,
they stopped doing couple's yoga over
there,
you know what I mean?
Like this is off putting to people and
just
hearing the southern drawl.
I mean we just don't hear it here.
Forgetting whether you like it or not.
Again,
you just simply don't hear it.
So yes,
I get a lot of like,
you know,
that Kinda thing.
But I mean I think it's funny,
you know,
it's fine.
I don't mind it.
So when I was watching a bunch of your
youtube videos in the last couple of
days,
I thought wow,
here is a liberal that I agree with on
so much.
And it's funny,
I told you before,
you know,
um,
I was born in Brooklyn,
I lived my whole life in New York City
until I moved out to la.
So the only two places I ever lived are
New York and La.
And then I watch your stuff and I find
this,
this Tennessee red neck who's a liberal
who I'm going,
this guy gets what?
Liberalism is a,
what do you sense about the general
state of liberalism because it's become
a,
like a hot button word that can be used
I guess a little bit in a positive way,
but almost at all levels now.
It's being used in a negative way.
Well,
yeah,
from my allies,
even from my liberal allies,
I think it's starting to.
I think it's to me in a lot of ways,
liberalism has jumped the shark.
Like it's just,
I've just went too far with so many
things and uh,
me and you were talking off air earlier
about the fact that like where I'm from,
right?
And we've already kind of touched on it,
but where I'm from and where I've spent
most of my life,
I'm like,
I'm Karl Marx,
man.
I'm like,
I'm as far left as it gets.
They're out here in California.
I'm a,
you know,
a centrist or whatever,
probably because that's just how much
further.
And it's true on both sides though,
is the thing.
It's like with the tea party and
whatever else and how it politically
we've been pushed to the polls,
you know,
the opposite extremes.
And it's absolutely true on the left
too.
And I don't really know what has
happened to cause that.
I think it's just like maybe the
cultural divide between the two and just
like,
you know,
going back and forth and sort of pushing
each other.
The distaste that each side has for the
other side just pushes them as far as
much further away from the opposition is
they can go or something.
There.
Again,
I'm just a comedian.
I'm pulling that out of my ass.
But like,
that's,
you know what I,
something like that.
I guess we'll look all of our own
personal experiences are what make the
reality of it.
Right.
So I mean that's exactly.
I've been talking about for a long time.
I've watched the left go off this way.
I've watched it,
right.
Go off this way.
I'm a firm believer that there's huge
spot right now for,
for people somewhere in the middle.
It's funny because I have a lot of
libertarians on and I now find much more
in common as a liberal with libertarians
that I do with leftist.
So what do,
what do we do with that as good liberals
that want to bring the left?
Well,
I can't ever get.
My thing is like uh,
economically might not across the board,
but in most ways economically,
like libertarianism is not familiar.
There's a lot of the shit that they
subscribe to that I don't at all.
So you went from being a firm bay,
so you want more of a state,
you see more utility for estate and
taxes.
I think.
I genuinely think that it's necessary
now,
don't get me wrong.
A lot of bloat,
like,
and it's,
it's at way out of hand and doesn't need
to be reined in some.
I know that it's also a little personal
to me because I said I went to business
school so I wasn't waiting tables doing
moonlighting as a comedian.
I worked for the US Department of
Energy.
That was my day job when I was like
getting into comedy.
And so,
I mean,
I know firsthand about like the bloat of
the federal government and the and the
inefficiencies of our bureaucracy and
all that and it needs to be cleaned up.
But I think it's necessary though that
you have a government that sort of
regulates and polices,
uh,
some of these other systems,
particularly basically my.
And I just don't trust rich people to do
what's right for everybody else.
I never have.
And I don't think I ever will because
that's just human nature.
I think they're going to do a trap for
them and the people live in their own
self interest,
not across the board,
but by and large.
And so I think we need systems in place
to sort of keep that from happening if
possible.
Yeah.
Isn't that the catch 22 also though,
because now the government is run by
rich people too and capitalism and all.
Well,
so it's like we either have business
rich people doing it or political rich
people and we're,
we're,
we're all kind of caught.
Well,
that's,
that's the thing is I'm a big believer
in that,
you know,
that we live in a plutocracy and that's
a big problem for me because of
everything I just said.
But that is the reality of it.
I do think,
yes,
the rich people run the government or
whatever and that,
you know,
that's a damn shame.
But like I'm saying philosophically,
I do think there's a definite need for
government.
Um,
I think you have to have it.
But,
uh,
but socially though,
and in a lot of other white
libertarians,
I'm absolutely more in line with them on
like,
I mean,
I,
I'm pro legalization of a really just
about any drug,
to be honest with you.
And uh,
I'm also pro gun,
uh,
growing up that that's the,
that's the least liberal thing about me,
but it's a,
to me it's a freedom thing and I'd
actually use a liberal thing,
but it's not a leftist that's the
difference between liberal to you can
protect yourself.
That is a liberal,
right?
I've actually,
I've never bought a gun.
I own 17 guns because I inherited my
grandfather's arsenal right now.
And so,
but I'm saying in the south where I'm
from that super common and so like,
it's not weird to me.
It's not like dangerous.
Like why would you want to own a gun?
I'm just like,
why wouldn't you want gun?
Like I,
I'm all for background checks and all
that kind of stuff.
The gun show loopholes and all that need
to be closed.
I'm all for all that.
But just generally speaking,
I got no problem with guns and um,
you know,
pro,
I'm very,
I'm a believer in freedom,
real freedom.
You know what I mean?
That's the way I've always looked at a
gay rights to,
you know what I mean?
Like he thought in the privacy of your
own home,
bedroom,
whatever else.
Go wild long as you're not hurting
anybody else who gives a shit.
Yeah.
So it's across the board for me.
Yeah,
you're a classical liberal,
but I guess for a,
uh,
a tour thing,
classical liberal,
you just dropped the class,
right?
Like,
well.
And also that,
and I mean I'm aware of the distinction
again philosophically,
but my whole life,
like in the south or in the rural south,
especially like a liberal's liberal
mind,
you know what I mean?
You're either a liberal or you're not
like classical versus progressive
liberal,
whatever it.
I don't know.
That shit matters where I'm from.
You know what I mean?
So like,
I never thought about it in those terms,
but.
But yes,
though,
I mean,
yeah,
you're right.
It's funny.
I definitely,
um,
yeah,
I,
I gotta get my show to,
to Tennessee then because that's what
I've been trying to do is show people
the difference between real liberalism
and what and what is happening.
Oh,
they definitely need that in the south
because that's the.
I mean,
right.
If they,
well that's the whole,
that's a big thing in the south for a
long time as people asked,
well,
why did they vote against their self
interest,
you know,
what I mean,
or whatever else.
And it's like,
well,
because they don't think that you
reflect their self interest,
you know what I mean?
And I think arguably a lot of liberal
policies do,
but all they know about liberals is this
like,
you know,
elitist,
a fru,
fru ovary,
overly pc,
like the,
you know,
um,
that whole thing is all that they're
aware of when it comes to liberals and,
and it's like a total nonstarter for
most of them.
Is that the funny thing about trump and
people in the south,
it's like they took really a New York,
really,
a New York Democrat.
He's a big government.
It's very clear.
He's a big government guy.
He's happy to do all these executive
orders,
right?
A rich guy and elitist all of those
things.
Now I get it.
He was out of the system.
He was out of the political system.
So he's thought of as an outsider,
but they,
oh,
he's eight.
You know,
he's not religious,
there's no reason to believe that he
believes in Christianity.
The one time he sweat during the whole
campaign was that he went to Liberty
University and I had to repeat the
Corinthians or whatever.
So it's like,
is that the irony with them?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
they love him.
And then
I,
I've actually,
I've thought,
and I've talked a lot about this exact
thing because I in this,
I feel so naive about this now,
but like I was genuinely stunned when
Donald trump actually won.
I knew that there was,
and I shouldn't have been because I'm
from where he won.
If anybody I should have been now.
I was like cautioning people that all
the time like,
look,
there's something real here.
But at the end of the day I didn't think
it would happen and I was shocked and
maybe the biggest reason is,
and I felt this way throughout his whole
campaign.
I was looking around like what is going
on?
Because I,
I,
this is not an assumption or a theory.
I promise you I know this to be true.
If could go back in time,
like five,
six years ago,
whenever it was before he first went
after Obama for being an African Muslim
or whatever.
If we could go back to pre that and you
polled rednecks,
rural working class Americans,
what do you think about Donald Trump?
Because Donald Trump's been famous for
decades.
So what do you think about Donald Trump?
The dude,
it would have been almost universally
negative.
I promise you.
They would have hated everything up and
they did hate everything about him until
he got into all this political shit and
started pandering to them that they were
like,
he's a,
he's an,
an,
a latest silver spoon up is I asked
Yankee who thinks he's better than
everybody and thanks,
he's better and thinks he knows
everything.
And he's like I said,
big city Democrat,
whatever,
like,
you know,
um,
they would have hated everything about
him.
And so the whole time I was,
you know,
him throughout his entire rise,
I was looking around like,
really?
This dude really?
And what that says to me,
or what I've told myself anyway to make
sense of it,
is that just goes to show how desperate
they were for a champion of any kind of
like they were so desperate for that,
that even Donald Trump was good enough
for them to fill that bill.
You know what I mean?
Do you think that's legit in a way?
Because I,
I get that from a lot of people.
I mean I get mail my,
my audiences all over the place from,
from far left people to anarchists to
everything everywhere.
But I get a lot of that people just
saying,
you know what,
I just the system,
it was just,
I've had it.
I just had it.
You think that's a legit reason to vote
for someone that you may have nothing in
common with it you may think is a snake
oil salesman.
Is that sometimes the right way to do
it?
Not to me,
no,
I've never agreed with that.
I've heard a lot of that to have a lot
of people.
So when I was talking about is a little
bit different when you talk about like
people in like my hometown where you
know,
they bind Nafta and they blamed the
Clintons and whatever else for the
factory leaving and all this.
It's more than just,
oh,
he's shaking the system up it.
He was making promises directly to them.
I'm going to bring your job back and
restore your livelihood and all this
stuff in that connected with people and
I don't think they thought he was a
snake oil salesman or even if deep down
maybe they did a little bit.
I think they lied to themselves and say,
and you know,
deluded themselves into believing he
wasn't.
But I've also encountered a lot of
people who are,
like you just said,
they're like,
you know,
what will shake things up.
That's what we need this guy.
Something different.
Whenever we nailed this system is
broken,
let's mix it up a little bit.
And I've never been on board with that.
Like the general premise of it.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
I kinda am with you.
But in this iteration,
really like,
this is how you want to manifest that is
through Donald Trump,
like,
Nah man,
give me the system for for eight more
years,
whatever,
and then let's get a different maverick
in there.
Isn't this guy,
you know,
I've never agreed with that.
Yeah.
Do you think we just sort of forget that
all of us forgetting what our political
allegiance is that we all kind of just
forget how actually good at here is
here.
Not to say that there aren't problems.
Of course,
yes,
but,
but that it's pretty damn good
man.
I've,
I've actually been trying to work on a
bit about that for a long time now about
basically that about things are better
here now than they've been for almost
any group of people you can name ever
before.
And that's even true for like,
you know,
rural white people except things were
better for them and like,
you know,
a couple decades ago.
But I'm saying if you go back further
than that,
right.
It wasn't so great.
It was absolutely horrible.
They were sharecroppers,
you know what I mean?
So they had a little window of like
prosperity,
there were small town,
America was a real thing and
industrialism and whatever else outside
of that little window of time though,
this is still better than they've had
historically ever before.
And that's true for most people.
And yes,
people absolutely lose sight of that.
It's also less violent now than it
historically than we've ever been.
It's ever been before.
And people forget all that too.
They're like,
yeah,
that drives me crazy sometimes because I
think people need to maintain that
perspective.
Like,
you know,
wow,
this is not armageddon.
You know what I mean?
Like shit is crazy.
But like we're still all right,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
what do you make about the Armageddon
people?
Because one of the things I talk about
here all the time is the free speech
situation,
which I think is going to get a lot
worse.
I mean,
it's very clear that a certain amount of
people now think it's okay to punch
Nazis or punch anyone you think might be
a Nazi.
And if someone's speaking at a school
you don't like,
you can burn down the school.
And all that stuff.
What do we do?
So what do us as the liberals in this
situation that are supposed to defend
free speech,
what do we do to to come some of these
people down?
I've been trying to figure it out.
I don't know that I got there yet.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not sure either because anytime I'm
gonna be honest.
Anytime that I've tried to like touch on
some of that because I have in some of
my videos I've tried to say things that
are in line with what we're talking
about right now and they never get the
kind of response that might other videos
just railing on trump or the writer
would ever do everything I've ever said
in any of my videos I believe and I,
that's my genuine thoughts.
But anything that's ever been in like
kind of challenging in that way.
They're always like,
you know,
I could.
It's almost like I can feel the internet
and being like,
no,
no.
Let's see.
We don't want to hear all that.
You know what I mean?
Like people just don't want to hear it.
I was.
So when I thought the left,
he's supposed to be the tolerance side,
I know the tolerant people and see that
it's been that way for my people my
whole life,
meaning,
like for years and years I've been very
aware of the hypocrisy of liberals who,
you know,
of horror,
any kind of intolerance and
discrimination being so openly prejudice
towards people like me.
Yeah.
And it's always been that way my whole
life.
It's been that way.
And I've always thought that was
bullshit.
Like,
do you not realize that that is still
that still intolerant and it's always
been that way about,
you know,
poor white trash rednecks,
whatever else.
But now it's like spreading into this
psych.
They're intolerant of anybody who
doesn't agree with them on every single
thing.
You're now you're,
you know,
you're a Nazi or whatever.
And uh,
stoking the fires of the Patriarchy and
all this shit because she,
I assume you were against punching the
Nazi,
right?
I don't want to put words in your mouth.
I'm against it.
I don't anything.
I take that back.
I don't give a shit.
You're a Nazi.
Got Punched.
Like getting punched is fine with me,
especially if you know,
but I wish it would have just happened
in a bar somewhere,
just whipped his ass or whatever because
he probably needs his ass whipped.
Uh,
but do I think that we need to make it a
thing where we just go around punching
people that say things we disagree with?
No,
absolutely not.
Even if they're Nazis,
it's like when they sell,
you defended the Ku Klux Klan or
whatever in a court case once over
freedom of speech issue and like that's
the way it should be.
You know what I mean?
That's fair.
Like,
yeah,
that to hell with the client they held
with Nazis.
Obviously we're in Indiana Jones again.
I know it's ridiculous like it,
it has,
it has to go both ways.
It's like,
and this is slightly different subject,
but it's like on the topic of what is
and is not okay to joke about.
It's like Trey Parker and Matt Stone set
on South Park.
They tackled it and they were like,
look,
either all of it's okay or none of it
is.
And that's how I feel about free speech
in general,
like you don't have to like the awful
shit that he's saying,
but this is America and he has the right
to say it.
You know what I mean?
Just like we have the right to say I
have the right man because I asked them.
I mean I'd go after a shitty white
people as that termed them hard all the
time.
Uh,
and you know,
if I didn't have the ability to do that,
I wouldn't be sitting here right now.
I wouldn't have a career.
I just be doing whatever else.
And I'm,
I'm,
I realized that,
so I'm not going to be hypocritical
inside that,
you know,
only I should have the right to do it
because I'm right and he's wrong.
But what I mean like,
and of course I believe that he's wrong,
but it doesn't matter.
That's not how it works.
You have to apply it,
you know,
across the board consistently.
It's almost like you have to have ideals
even when they're hard to have.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Right?
Yeah.
How many years you've been doing
standup?
Six and a half.
Six and a half,
man,
I did 12 years of stand up before you
got into all this.
I started doing all this crazy shit and
I was telling you before how I got to
start doing it again now and I've been
speaking to colleges and stuff and sort
of working some standup in because I see
there's such a need for people to say
some uncomfortable things.
But I'm curious.
In your six and a half years,
have you seen the way language has
changed?
Was there something that you might've
said six years ago that you think now?
Just because everyone's on twitter and
snapchat and your whole set and all that
shit?
Yeah.
That you'd be afraid of saying
it's hard as a comedian and sit here
inside of that.
I'm afraid of saying anything but um,
but yes,
like one thing that bothers me is like
if I'm doing,
and I,
and I still do a lot of this and I can
feel people pull back sometimes,
but usually it's so it's okay,
but if I'm doing a bit about something,
uh,
that shitty people do or believe.
Right.
And so like in the bit I'm talking about
this hypothetical racist or bigoted or
whatever,
and like you say,
you know,
like if it's a homophobic thing and you
in the bit I say queer or gay or Faggot
or whatever,
but it's not me saying it,
I'm talking about this guy saying it and
then I tear that do apart right after
that for being shitty.
But it doesn't matter to a lot of people
just having said the word,
they're like,
Oh God,
no,
why would you do that?
It's like you're not listening to me and
I don't like to sugarcoat things and act
like that's not how those people are.
You know what I mean?
That's what that hypothetical dude would
say.
And that's the whole point of this whole
bit or whatever.
But none of that matters to people.
All that matters is literally just the
word,
the buzz words or whatever.
And sometimes it's like buzz ideas or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
You're just not allowed to joke about or
talk about no matter what.
Yeah,
absolutely hate that.
And that that's the death of comedy
because need satire.
So you're trying to sat tire something
to point out hypocrisy or whatever,
you know,
the,
the Charlie Hebdo people,
people say,
well they were mocking Muhammad,
they were mocking extremists actually.
And there in lies the rub.
I used to do a bit about,
uh,
about the transformers before they were
the movies from the eighties
transformers,
how they were all different racial
people.
And I used to act out a thing,
jazz.
He was the one black transformative to
say the n word on onstage and it would
always get a huge laugh.
And I remember one time that it got it
suddenly got a grown from a certain
amount of the crowd.
And I remember thinking,
Wow,
I'm never going to tell that joke again
and I have no desire to say then where
do.
It was just me acting out this fictional
robot,
futuristic robot that doesn't exist but
satire and this is
gotten better for me for sure.
Because most people at my shows in
particular,
they sort of know what I'm about,
know what they're getting into.
But like,
man,
with this accent,
you literally can't even say black
people.
You know what I mean?
Black people,
they're just like,
oh Jesus,
what?
This is about to be terrible.
You know what I mean?
Like people immediately recoil because
of just the way it sounds.
So I mean,
yes,
I've definitely dealt with that kind of
thing and one a and one of my first one,
my earliest videos,
I remember I was acting out,
my great,
great grandmother know who's dead and I
said,
you know,
she's dead,
but if she was still alive,
she wouldn't be comfortable eating
cornbread next to a colored boy.
Right.
Because she wouldn't even colored boys
is cleaning it up,
you know what I mean?
That's what she would say,
but it's like closer to it and I still
got so many messages from people that
were like,
I don't,
I don't know if you know this or maybe
it's different in Tennessee,
but we don't really say anymore.
That kind of thing.
It's like,
oh,
fucking course.
I know that that's the point of the
joke,
that it's this antiquated out of date
ideal that she would have,
and I'm making fun of it,
but just the word just calling,
referring to a black person as colored,
no matter the context,
set some people off and it's that whole
attitude.
It's like that is the reason that so
many people hate liberals
is that kind of thing because it's just
ridiculous how.
What about the idea that so you,
you make that joke about your great,
great grandpa and that people now look
at historical figures and try to give
them the morality of 2017 like I would
guess.
I Dunno,
but I would guess your great,
great grandmother probably was a pretty
decent one.
One and raised some kids and blah,
blah,
blah.
Yes.
Maybe she had.
There were some racial stuff there too,
which decided that,
but that we suddenly give our morality
of today to everyone else.
That's a really dangerous thing to do,
isn't it?
Yeah,
without a doubt that that's another
thing too,
like um,
that's a big reason why I try to be a
little more like understanding or I'm
not just so immediately like I'll fuck
you to people on the far right or
whatever because I've known so many of
them and loved them.
You know what I mean?
Like my grandparents,
both my grandfathers are dead.
If they were here though,
they probably would have voted for
Donald Trump.
Right.
I love the shit out of both of my
grandpas.
I miss them all the time,
you know what I mean?
And like people just shouldn't be,
but they were from,
they're from a different time,
you know what I mean?
Like they weren't bad people but like
both of them and the n word.
Oh God,
you know what I mean all the time.
But like that was just,
it was like,
that's just how people talked when they
were,
when they were growing up over their
lives or whatever.
I remember one time it was just a true
story,
and this is,
this is in my book too,
but there was a fight between a white
kid and a black kid in the town down
town,
like the town square of Salon in my
hometown when I was in high school,
small town.
Everybody's talking about it because the
white kid got the shit beat out of it
and uh,
everybody was talking about it and so I
was at my grandpa's car lot the next day
and he asked me what was that about,
what happened?
And I was like,
well,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I think Jimmy called Jimmy called the n
word or something,
something like that.
And My grandpa goes,
oh,
what the hell do you want him to call
him Chinese?
It is,
here's I loved.
Yeah.
And like it was,
he wasn't trying to be funny,
he wasn't trying to,
you know,
like that,
that was his genuine first thought and
it's,
he's just a product of his time and
that's how so and that my grandpa was
born in 1935.
So when you start talking about people
in the 18 hundreds or whatever,
yeah,
trying to apply today's standards to
them is ridiculous.
You know what I mean?
I'm curious,
do you ever get it the other way where
you'll say something about redneck
culture and people that are still part
of that culture will be like,
hey,
you're making us all look like idiots.
Are you making us all look backwards or
whatever?
Um,
I get a of,
and especially in my hometown,
I get a lot of,
oh,
he's selling his people out like that.
I'm just like exploiting them for like a
gimmick or whatever,
but it's not a gimmick.
It's,
it is who I am.
So I don't look at it that way at all.
Also,
anybody that grew up with me should know
better because as we talked about
earlier,
like I've always been this guy that none
of them shouldn't be surprised by this.
And uh,
but I get a lot of that.
But now I remember what I said earlier
about rednecks and not giving a damn
what people think.
I don't get much of like,
you know,
or you shouldn't be making fun of me,
my own,
you know,
or whatever.
Like I'll just get like,
fuck you,
but not in a like they're not,
not in the wet.
Yes.
I'm a queer to not,
not in the way that they're offended by
the redneck jokes.
They're offended by my ideas.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
that's about it.
I don't really get a lot of like,
oh,
you're going to solve look by eye
because they genuinely,
for the most part,
don't give a shit how they look to other
groups of people or whatever.
There's all this really show how
important comedy is to almost everything
because if you look at,
at foxworthy and those guys,
he was the redneck comedy tour,
right?
And that's what it's called,
blue collar,
blue collar comedy tour.
Um,
that,
that was finally an outlet for some of
these people that we're talking about,
to just have their shit hurt.
And that's just an incredibly powerful
thing.
Yeah.
I,
I completely agree and totally think
that comedy is more important now than
it's been in a long time.
A weirdly enough,
and I,
I didn't,
uh,
I didn't check this,
this is just in the middle of another
interview for a UK magazine and so I'm
talking to this,
a British reporter and she was talking
about,
she asked me a question apparently
Armando Iannucci,
you know,
that his iep for vape and he made a in
the loop the movie and before that,
in the UK,
the thick of it,
I'm a huge fan of that guy,
colossal fanny's when my favorite comedy
writers on planet Earth and she just.
And she was like,
did you hear what he said the other day?
And I didn't know,
I guess it was news over there or
whatever.
And she said that according to her he
said that he thinks that it's time to
step away from joking about a lot of
these things because we need to take it
seriously and not joke about it.
And I told her,
I was like,
well,
I still love his work and I'm a huge
fan,
but I could not possibly disagree more
strongly with that.
Especially if you're talking about,
I'm a comedian,
he's a comedy writer,
you know,
like that's my whole job is to make fun
of Shit and I think you need comedy in
times like this because it otherwise
it's just darkness.
It makes it easier to deal with because
like I'm,
yeah,
Oh,
you know,
people do need to talk about it.
Seriously.
The people like politicians and people
are actually in the field or whatever.
They do need to take this shit
seriously.
They absolutely do because it's very
serious.
But I'm a comedian.
I don't need to take it.
That's not my role.
My role is to take the piss out of it,
to use,
you know,
his vernacular and like I don't know why
we would stop now.
For me,
it's more important now than ever it is.
And again,
if he,
if he didn't actually say that,
then you know,
whatever,
what we're going to click and send it
directly to that.
But according to a British reporter,
that was a quote from him and I was,
I was just kind of floored,
like,
no,
it's not opposite.
I've seen a lot of that though.
We're comics,
I mean people that I generally respect
and like where they've gone off the deep
end where it's like,
no,
they're not being funny anymore.
They're,
they're just preaching all the time and
it's like if George Carlin was around,
and I say this on the show almost every
week,
like every morning I wake up and I'm
like,
fuck,
where the hell is George Carlin?
And when we need it more than ever,
he would still be being funny about this
and that.
And that goes to prove your point.
That's what we need.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Well,
we did it.
We did a New Yorker,
La guy and a redneck.
We did an hour.
This has been an hour.
I didn't look down once.
We didn't even stop.
We said we were going to stop once we
rolled right through.
We didn't even start.
Flew by.
It flew by.
I have a feeling we're going to cross
paths again.
I think so.
I hope so.
I hope so too.
Thanks for having me,
man.
I shouldn't have been out to la for a
month.
Jesus.
It'll be a month and a like four or five
more days.
Yeah.
Well you should.
You probably got to get a spray Tan and
have a trainer yet or not eating or
eating carbs.
Can you get off all the carbs?
All the car,
but all the gluten,
dairy,
all that.
I'm doing a piss poor job of that.
That part of being a California and we
did a man,
cory and drew.
We came out here and one of the first
things we did was shotgun some liquor.
Always just exploded in the mindset.
So yeah.
I'm,
you know,
I'm dipping my toes in the water.
Small steps.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well it was,
it was a pleasure chatting with users.
All my guys for more on and to find out
his tour dates on the well read comedy
tour.
Check out facebook.com/trae
crowder.